[Music]
our favorite fixer-upper couple chip and
Joanna Gaines also have something pretty
big to celebrate the arrival of baby
number five welcome to the world baby
boy
crew number five the number five was you
know number five I think it's symbolic
for grace crew Gaines arrived Thursday
two and a half weeks early which is
fitting since baby number five was a
sweet surprise from day one joanna
posted we couldn't be more in love
sharing several photos including this
one of the couple's four older kids
waiting outside the hospital room to
meet their new baby brother as for cruz
named while the couple broke family
tradition both their boys names start
with addy drake and duke the girls have
a names Ella and Emmie but Joanna
revealed she was pushing for baby number
five to have a cname name he wants the D
name and get this chip may have been
dropping hints about the baby's name as
far back as April he posted this pic of
their kids captioned I love my crew the
arrival of baby crew is part of a new
chapter for the couple who wrapped the
fifth and final season a fixer-upper in
April when you think about raising a
family four kids 12 and under at this
point I mean you know it gets
complicated you just felt right for us
to take a timeout step back see if we
couldn't catch our breath and see what's
next
[Music]
you
[Music]